; .c... vérifié 5:18
- Sibole!
- Michel Rivard, vous faites
un retour au petit écran dans
"Nuit blanche", saga familiale.
Pourquoi ce retour au jeu?
MICHEL RIVARD, auteur-
compositeur-interprète, comédien
- Le retour au jeu est toujours,
chez moi, une fête parce que
j'aime jouer. J'ai toujours aimé
ça. Ça me rapproche beaucoup
de mon père. Ça me rapproche
beaucoup du métier que j'ai vu
de mon père... manier avec
beaucoup d'aisance et beaucoup
de talents, quand j'étais jeune.
Donc, apprendre les textes
de quelqu'un d'autre, me plier
aux exigences d'un personnage,
puis tout ça.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je suis allé fouillé dans
nos archives : à l'âge de 7 ans,
vous décrochez votre
premier rôle, 1958.
- Oui.
- Quels souvenirs gardez-vous
de cette époque-là?
C'était la série...
comment elle s'appelait?
- "CF-RCK".
- J'avoue que c'est magnifique!
- Et moi, je fais... si ma
mémoire est bonne, mon rôle
est celui d'un enfant qui s'est
pris la patte dans un piège.
Et mon rôle consistait à gémir.
(rires)
- Gros rôle de composition!
- Gros rôle de composition parce
que même à 8 ans, je n'avais
jamais eu la patte prise
dans un piège. Donc, j'ai dû
m'imaginer. Mais je me souviens
que, en fait, il y a eu
plusieurs rôles à partir de ça.
J'ai joué dans "Rue de l'anse",
une série dramatique. Entre...
entre 15 et... 15 et 20 ans,
j'étais dans "Rue des Pignons".
Mon père aussi, d'ailleurs.
On a des scènes ensemble
même à certains moments.
Et ça, je n'aimais pas
tellement ça parce que moi,
déjà, j'avais un pied dans
la musique et dans l'humour
absurde. Ça, j'avoue,
bien humblement, je bats
ma coulpe, je le faisais pour
pouvoir m'acheter une guitare,
puis un ampli!
- C'était ma question!
Est-ce que vos premiers rôles,
vous les avez faits pour vous
payer une première guitare?
- Celui-là, oh, oui! Celui-là.
- Pour "Rue des Pignons".
- Avant ça, c'était...
j'étais plus jeune, puis
j'aimais... j'aimais la faire.
- Je vous ai rarement vu
aussi énergique, aussi heureux.
Est-ce que c'est le succès
de "L'Origine de mes espèces"?
C'était un projet qui vous
tenait tellement à coeur.
Et j'ai l'impression de
redécouvrir Michel Rivard.
On dirait que vous avez fait
la paix avec quelque chose.
- J'ai fait la paix
avec beaucoup de choses, avec
certains aspects de mes parents,
individuellement et ensemble.
Et aussi avec Beau Dommage,
aussi avec toutes mes chansons.
♪ Ça vaut pas la peine
de laisser ceux qu'on aime ♪
Comme beaucoup de monde,
à un moment donné, on a...
on a une espèce de prétention
de dire : "Arrêtez de me gosser
avec 'La complainte du phoque en
Alaska', écoutez ce que je viens
d'écrire, là, t'sais."
C'est important ce que je viens
d'écrire. La prochaine chanson
est importante, mais je ne dois
jamais oublier ce qui fait que
je suis encore là aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qui a motivé les gens
à continuer à m'encourager
et à me suivre. Et c'est
certaines chansons et
je dois jamais oublier ça.
Je dois jamais oublier ça parce
que les gens qui ont embarqué
là-dedans font que je gagne
encore ma vie à faire ça.
- Le premier album du groupe
Beau Dommage a été remixé.
- Oui.
- Il va être réédité en 2022.
- Comment gérez-vous
le patrimoine de Beau Dommage
et comment vous voyez
ce remixage-là?
- Bien, moi, en autant que...
en autant que ce n'est pas
bassement mercantile, c'est-à-
dire quand il y a un intérêt
artistiquement valable.
Il n'y aura pas de surprise,
mais comme... et là, on en est
les maîtres, alors on les
assume, comme dans les remixages
des Beatles par Giles Martin,
tout ce qu'on a, c'est de
l'amour. On a de l'amour
qui nous permet de dire :
"Ah, il y avait trois guitares
à ce moment-là" ou "il y avait
quatre harmonies de voix".
Et c'est juste ça.
- Et Beau dommage va avoir
50 ans, en 2024.
- Ouais.
- Je ne veux pas que vous
fassiez comme les Rolling Stones
là, mais t'sais je sais pas, un
concert, sortir Pierre Bertrand
de sa tannière dans le fin fond
du bois!
- Honnêtement, honnêtement,
peut-être si tous les membres
de Beau Dommage avaient continué
à être vraiment actifs
régulièrement, musicalement,
je dirais : pourquoi pas.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Déjà, les retours qu'on a faits
ont demandé beaucoup de travail
et beaucoup d'eau dans le vin
aussi, parce qu'on est très
différents. Et Dieu merci, ça a
réussi! Alors, ne prenons pas de
chance. Je pense que les shows
de Beau Dommage sont de beaux
souvenirs pour tout le monde,
ceux qui les ont vus et ceux
qui les ont faits, t'sais.
- Cette entrevue-là a vraiment
été un immense cadeau.
Merci beaucoup.
- Merci à vous.